et maintenant nous vous emmenons à Hackensack New
Jersey pour une annonce spéciale qui
a fait
ce show Chucky reviendra le
4 octobre et je ne me reposerai pas jusqu'à ce que
chacun d'entre vous le regarde, connards, maintenant
posez-moi quelques questions Chucky, qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette saison à propos de tout  Je dirai que DC va se
retrouver avec tellement de
contenu là-bas, où pouvons-nous regarder les
informations, c'est trop gros pour une seule plate-forme,
donc mon émission fonctionne sur trois science-fiction américaines
et Pika prochaine vie rapide et bien, Devin Sawa
reviendra  en tant que nouveau personnage,
question suivante, que diriez-vous de Jennifer
Tilly, sera-t-elle de retour oui, vous savez, elle
revient toujours ici Chucky
Chucky Chucky Chucky Chuck, quelle est votre
réponse aux critiques qui disent qu'il y a
eu beaucoup trop de films de poupées récemment,
je dirais  ce n'est pas un film j'ai déjà
fait sept films c'est une émission de télévision je suis
désolé la
question est que je viens pour toi
merci ouais